aquí
soy emanuel tengo 22 años soy de
illinois un pequeño pueblo llamado james
y estoy en la escuela a tiempo completo
quisiera trabajar como agente deportivo
hola chicas
un placer conocerlas
hola cómo está la que forma de
conocernos igualmente sería mejor en
persona esto es muy raro sí así es
y hay muchos delay porque usted hace una
foto de kobe les quería preguntar sobre
eso pero creo ser el primero en
explicarlo entonces elegí esa foto
porque siempre lo admiré mucho y soy
fanático del baloncesto y los deportes
que interesante juegas baloncesto cuál
es tu equipo favorito y viéndolo jugar
mi juego baloncesto pero no como
profesional sólo por interesante ha sido
algún juego reciente mi equipo favorito
son los lakers
alguna es fan de los metieron juega bien
juego el mes pasado yo igual me gusta
jugar pero no soy muy atlética genial el
baloncesto es muy divertido derriba los
lakers y un juego creo que hace un mes
la vibra de la cancha es genial hace
mucho que no voy no sé mucho sobre los
lakers quisiera conocer a alguien que me
enseñara si verlos jugar en la arena es
genial qué pena que le cambiaron el
nombre es cierto hoy me enteré de que
ahora se llama creep no es del mejor
nombre si la vibra ya no es la misma
bien chicas porque dirigieron las fotos
que están usando
es triste pero nunca será el mismo este
tipo se entera sin kobe la mía es de mi
perro con anteojos y también no son
chaleco rosa
me encanta la canción de hollywood de
gwen stefani pero es muy largo para un
alias así que lo abre bien mi perro se
llama sony y tiene 15 años porque drug
lord
[Música]
es por un concierto al que fui ir a los
conciertos es una de mis cosas favoritas
la energía de la música en vivo es
increíble la mía es de mi gato tarot
cuando era pequeña y mi foto es de un
hongo porque me gustan las cosas
psicodélicas y rosa negra del año pasado
como farmaceuta así que técnicamente soy
el lord de losar más gustan los
conciertos espero ir a uno pronto cuál
sería tu concierto ideal mi concierto
ideal sería uno de tres aún no lo he
visto en vivo drake no acaba de dar un
concierto cuál es tu canción favorita de
trail es increíble fui a uno de esos
conciertos desde un gran artista lo
siento tu canción cuando sea el momento
adecuado
creo que la buena ortografía no es
nuestro fuerte no
además de los conciertos y el baloncesto
tienes otro es para satin no tengo una
canción favorita pero con marvin su room
me identifico con la letra
por cierto puede tocar hotline en mikel
l
marc this room es muy buena chicas
cuáles son sus pasatiempos e intereses
les diré los míos amo la música toca el
violín por 13 años ahora me aventuro con
el l comencé a patinar el año pasado y
me encanta también me gusta ir a
conciertos y a festivales como ya dije
lo que más me gusta hacer es ir a
conciertos además de lo que ya he dicho
me gusta ir a bares también a la playa
disfrutar el momento me gusta la
aventura
qué divertido este es el mejor lugar
para hacer todo eso puedo enseñarte a
mezclar música
no quiero hacerlo
lo siento brócoli gal haz los ciento o
la
desgracia no me gustan mucho los gatos
ella parecía la señora de los gatos así
la percibí no lo digo a modo ofensivo
solo lo pensé te ves bien
igualmente fue un rico gracias encantado
de conocerte soy erika lamento que no te
gustan sus lindos pero tú te lo pierdes
elegí brócoli gal porque me gusta el
brócoli si no te gusta el brócoli ni los
gatos no no eres para mí encantada de
conocerte encantado de conocerte lo
siento poco legal
cuáles son sus metas y aspiraciones
profesionales me tome las cosas con
calma después de que me gradué pero
ahora estoy preparándome para iniciar
una especialización
quiero terminar la universidad aquí en
california y espero convertirme en
agente deportivo luego de hacer un
posgrado en gestión deportiva
quiero ser terapeuta creo que muchos de
nuestros problemas son por traumas de la
infancia así que quiero ayudar a los
demás todos merecemos ser felices
estudio producción de cine y televisión
trabajar con una gran productora como
directora creativa y estoy pensando
iniciar una pasantía en una agencia
publicitaria mientras estoy estudiando
genial tengo amigas farmaceutas que
interesante con qué deporte quieres
trabajar balance ni trabajo ideal sería
en psiquiatría o en oncología me
interese por los fármacos para el cáncer
desde que publiqué mi primer artículo
clínico para los nuevos fármacos de
cáncer de pulmón no microcítico genial
no existe en california yo también
quiero hacer un postgrado me gustan los
chicos cultos con baloncesto claro pero
me gustaría trabajar con todos los
deportes posibles fútbol boxeo y béisbol
prácticas todos estos deportes juegas
baloncesto en forma ocasional cómo
empezaste no soy de california soy de
illinois me mudé aquí en septiembre y
amo este lugar
oye espera también soy de al medio este
grillo de qué parte de illinois hola
paisano increíble la familia de mi padre
esté allá los visité un tiempo esto es
una gran casualidad comencé a jugar mal
encima de desde los 8 años en casa
siempre jugaba con mis amigos soy de un
pueblo al oeste a unas dos horas de
chicago la última vez que visité a mi
familia fue navidad
como la pasaste debe ser genial estar en
casa de que parte de indiana eres
conozco las dunas volverías a illinois
mi padre dice que le gusta mucho más
aquí que chicago y todos mis primos
ahora quieren venir muchos de mis amigos
son de chicago por lo tanto haré una
pregunta importante quiera ser mejor la
pizza giordano solo si me gusta volver
para visitar a mi familia es lo mejor
giordano si no he ido chicago pero me
gustaría conocerlo también visité a mi
familia en navidad y fue increíble
jordan os es lo mejor siempre como allí
estoy sorprendido de que tanta gente
aquí conozca a giordano porque son los
mejores sitios de pizza si quieres pizza
vas a giordano so a rosati te quería
preguntar si había comido en rosati hay
uno aquí a la vuelta de cadena de más y
el otro día no sabía que había un
giordano por aquí sería buena idea
entonces iremos los dueños son muy
amables
rayos voy a eliminar
the real slim shady
fue una mala elección
así que sí bueno creo que no pude
integrarlos en la segunda ronda cuando
empezaron a hablar del medio este no
tenía mucho que añadir a la conversación
sé lo que es mudarse y conocer a alguien
que es del mismo lugar se forma una
conexión es un enorme punto en común no
me sorprendió ser eliminada pareces una
gran persona es curioso lo mismo de ti
rayos
[Música]
hola chicos soy milk y todos sabemos que
las citas son duras pero desde el
estómago conquistas del corazón queremos
dar las gracias a hello fresh por
patrocinar esta parte del vídeo hello
fresh es una empresa de comida que
ofrece una gran variedad de recetas
rápidas y fáciles que minimiza la
preparación me cuesta pensar en lo que
quiero cocinar por eso me encanta que le
ofrece sus recetas sencillas
ingredientes frescos y proporcionados
así que cocinar sea fácil se reduce el
tiempo de preparación y los viajes al
supermercado y hoy hello fresh ofrece
hasta 16 comidas gratis y 3 regalos
sorpresa con hello fresa es fácil
ajustar el tamaño de tu pedido para
ayudar a planificar las comidas para
grupos o para ti es genial porque una de
mis cosas favoritas en la oficina es
almorzar con el resto del equipo de
jubilee visita la página de help of
friends puntocom y utiliza el código
jubilee dieciséis para obtener hasta 16
comidas gratis y 3 regalos sorpresa
recuerda usa el código civil y 16 para
obtener 16 comidas gratis y 3 regalos
sorpresa ahora volvamos al vídeo
con quién eres más cercano en tu familia
con mi mamá a ella es como mi mejor
amiga y siempre me brinda su apoyo soy
igual que tú aprecio mucho un compañero
que sea cercano a su familia también
genial yo también lo que más les gusta
de la familia chicas mi papá y yo somos
muy amigos es muy divertido siempre me
inspira dar lo mejor de mí me inspiró a
correr en la playa pronto va a correr su
octavo maratón mi papá y yo tenemos una
relación difícil pero me preocupo por él
y le agradezco lo que ha hecho por mí
creerán que bromeó pero tengo una
hermana menor con quien siempre
intercambio ropa y hacemos las mismas
cosas es una mini yo qué bueno que
puedas ver lo positivo de la relación
que tienes con tu padre alguien ya
pregunto sobre esto pero háblanos de tus
hermanos y te no es fácil ver siempre lo
positivo siento si tengo una hermana
menor y un hermano mayor tengo una
hermana menor a quien amo con todo mi
corazón que se siente ser el hijo de en
medio daría la vida por mis hermanos
aunque espero que eso no pase la
diferencia de edad es muy grande porque
entre mi hermana y yo no lo es y cuando
tenga hijos quisiera que fuera igual
yo nunca te olvidare con tus hijos les
gustaría tener yo quisiera tener más
hermanos prefieres una familia grande o
pequeña no más de dos también yo os
diría que mis hijos nos superarán en
número a mi pareja ya mí eso es muy
gracioso
la verdad fue hace un tiempo siempre no
siempre pero he tenido relaciones
casuales me gusta hablar con otras
personas pero no intimar con ellas si
eso tiene sentido una relación real no
he tenido ninguna desde que estaba creo
que en secundaria no lo sé creo que soy
muy como se dice quisquilloso supongo
puedo quedarme con ambas no es broma
esto es muy difícil
pero
pero voy a tener que eliminar a the
truck lord
[Música]
cómo estás soy lo que esperabas qué
sería
de hecho si una chica como
ninguno de los dos parece una persona
del medio efe
vas a dar gracias es un placer conocer
ha sido un placer conocerte lamento que
haya más
me gustaría conocer tu elección y
hagámoslo
hola cómo estás o no estás con mucho
gusto
soy lo que esperaba bueno no me gusta
generar me expectativas pero no puedo
negar que eres hermosa gracias número
porque no podríamos darnos una
oportunidad sí seguro bueno rosati no
sabía que había uno por aquí sin duda
iremos a rosati supo que ambos somos del
medio
es muy raro porque sólo he estado allí
un par de veces